and and here's what i think i don't
necessarily think young people are any
different than we were gen x
i agree with you i don't think they're
any different actually i think they're
better
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
hey everybody it's gary vaynerchuk uh as
many of you know
uh for quite a while now i haven't been
doing too many interviews on the podcast
but i'm
super excited to break that pattern for
a very special uh
uh interview this morning uh and uh
really just wishing everybody tremendous
health and perseverance through this uh
challenging 2020 for a trillion
different reasons
and i'm really excited because uh i know
the feeling of having a new book out
six times five in the business sector
one in the wine sector and
and i'm really really excited to have
this uh
wonderful guest with us uh this morning
guy uh why don't you tell
everybody a little bit about yourself
then we'll get into the book and then
we'll
shoot the uh [ __ ] in the macro uh but
first of all guy how are you guy raz is
with us this morning
um thanks gary i'm you know i'm fine you
know i think as you said
uh it's weird because my my general kind
of disposition is to be optimistic
and positive and it's it's a grind to do
that in 2020 2020 is challenged i think
um
a lot of us to to get up in the morning
and to you know fight another day um
but in general you know i'm i'm i'm
doing fine you know i've got i've got
um great kids and and
and wife and i'm we're really lucky you
know we've been we've been okay
um so for for those who you know who
don't know who i am i'm the host of how
i built this
um it's a show i created four years ago
i've been
in broadcasting my whole career um i
started out as an
intern at npr in the mid 90s and even
before that guy
what about like before we even get into
the profession just since we have a
little bit of time it'll be fun
where'd you grow up what kind of kid
were you yeah sibling situation if any
like
give us give us the comic book one sure
story chapter one yeah um i grew up in
in the san fernando valley in los
angeles actually
um i have uh two older sisters and
younger brother
um my dad number three of four remember
three four
my dad um was an engineer and my mom was
a teacher
and at the age of 41 my dad decided to
um start his own business so he started
a pearl store he still sold pearls
with my mom um and that was my first
sort of taste of entrepreneurship how
how old were you when he was 41 i was i
think i was
maybe six seven years old okay
yeah so you really kind of at some level
mainly remember him as an entrepreneur
i do and i remember him um cold calling
people
and going door to door in downtown l.a
trying to sell pearls
um at the age of 41 you know with three
kids at the time do you have any sense
of
what got him going on pearls well we
lived in japan my dad was an
engineer or um he worked for a freight
company called flying tigers which was
then purchased by fedex
and while he was in japan he met um a a
guy there who was like hey you should go
to la i've got a pearl company here
and you should you know i can be your
supplier and you should start a pearl
store there so
that's really how it happened he had no
he had no background in pearls he didn't
really
he spent years learning about them and
became an expert actually he's retired
today
and became a gemologist but that was his
beginning he started this little pro
store
in downtown l.a and that's how he
sustained his family for the rest of his
life
was entrepreneurship something that was
in the family from either your mother or
dad's side
grandparents great grandparents for you
yeah i mean you know i think like
like a lot of people with my background
you know my my family comes from
eastern europe and many of them ended up
not surviving the holocaust
the ones who did survive um kind of had
to had to be reborn i mean they were
they grew up at a time where um you know
they were
my grandmother was nurse my grandfather
was a plumber um
you know that that was did they were
they born in the old country
i don't know if you know this but i was
born in the soviet yeah i know i know
i know so i always resonate with these
stories but i always tell my friends and
contemporaries
you know i'm far more like your
grandfather than i am like you because i
came over on the boat in the 70s which
was rare but a lot of these families
came over in 20s 30s 40s
my grandfather was a um
he he grew up in ukraine um and he was
basically um he was sent to prison
by this by the by the communists by the
soviets because
when he was a student um he was it was
uh
the book by theodore herzl was found
which was the ghost called the jewish
state was founded in his
in his room my grandfather was not a
zionist he didn't really know much about
it
he wasn't interested in it but his he
was set up
so he went to siberia for three years
actually
two-person camp and when he got out he
left got it
um and that was sort of this the
beginning of
and that was your dad's dad that's my
mom's dad yeah your mom dad excuse me
and your dad's dad your dad's family
similar also from you know most most
jews
um of european descent were come from
this area called the pale of settlement
which is sort of between the german
empire and the russian empire they were
forced to live there actually
and so um most jews of european descent
can
trace their lineage to to the people
that they prepared and many of them were
extremely poor i mean they lived in in
the
shuttle than the original ghettos and uh
uh
and and so they weren't you know
educated um cultured people i mean they
were working grinders
grinders yes was edu for that reason
the modern second third generation in
the us
very pushed on education was that a
big you know oh and then your mom's a
teacher so are you
are you hearing that propaganda as a kid
like get a good go to a great college go
to
college how old are you guys i'm 45.
right so say i turned 45 in november so
same age group
like that you know i someone who became
kind of
a public entrepreneur i try to tell a
lot of 20 year olds
you don't understand this is the era
where entrepreneurship is cool
i was actually a bad student a great
entrepreneur but every teacher
and friend's parent thought i was going
to be a loser
that's how much the brand of good
college dominated
the 70s and 80s yes and 90s yeah yes and
90s
i agree and and and i think that that
brand of
of prestigious colleges is really waning
and will continue to wane
and i think about this a lot as i save
the money and my kids 529 plans
often wondering what is this going to be
for it's a funny conversation guy
because
in parallel i also think you're seeing
the vulnerability of the entrepreneurial
brand because everyone's doing it
but it's a talent it's like everyone
deciding they're going to be an nba
player
it is actually very difficult to be a
successful sustainable entrepreneur
um and i actually think the brand of
entrepreneurship has gotten a little bit
more like
fratty clubby cool like or trying to be
cool
it's actually lost a little bit of its
luster as well so now you've got these
two dynamics
where both are going through an
interesting transformation it'll be
interesting to see what evolves from
that
you know um i really think that we need
to work on redefining what it means to
be an entrepreneur actually
taking it back to what it actually
really means because
my grandfather was an entrepreneur he
was a plumber he employed two people
right my dad was an entrepreneur he had
a jewelry store in downtown l.a selling
pearls
and my mother was worked with him and he
had two employees
that's that's i mean the person who runs
the corner grocery store here in oakland
where i am
is a successful entrepreneur actually
more profitable than uber
well it's funny it's funny when you know
there's a video of me on the internet
on an early bloomberg tv episode
of a show that was focusing on tech
stars very early on in this web 2.0
bubble
and there's like eight it's almost like
a last episode of real world where
there's eight companies that went
through the show
and fred wilson and all you know a lot
of people are sitting there with me on
the panel
kind of recapping the season and every
company gets up
and they and they kind of talk about
what's happened since the show
and eight of the nine companies end with
and we've raised three million dollars
you know and the crowd goes crazy and
then finally one company goes up and
says well we haven't raised any money
we've actually been able to get clients
the guy i'm not kidding dead silence i
grab the mic and i go this is what's
wrong
yeah i'm like i'm like we're cheering
giving up a piece of your business and
losing money
and we're staying silent for people that
have actually executed entrepreneurship
a thousand percent and i talk about this
in my book i mean i i
i am a huge huge believer in
bootstrapping and i'm a huge believer in
in trying to if you're if you are
seeking out money
you know trying to seek it out from
individuals and institutional family you
know
foundational investors not venture
capitalists or private equity because i
think you're exactly right you know we
we we think that success is raising a
lot of money now look raising a lot of
money is really hard it's hard to do
you've got to convince people that
you've got a great product and it's
certainly
would you agree with me and i'm sorry to
cut you off would you agree with me that
the thing we maybe didn't understand as
well a half decade ago that's becoming
more obvious
is just how much money is in the system
how much money is actually being printed
where some of these money start coming
from whether it's saudi or
softbank or things that they like there
is a little bit more of an
understanding that wait a minute and
then you also had the phenomenon of
instagram facebook and others where you
had
your corner entrepreneur that was in her
his
50s 60s 70s getting excited right about
writing a 50 000
check into their son's best friend
because they were looking for their
lottery ticket as the brand of
startups happened yes yes and
and you know the reality is as you as
you point out i mean there is
it's estimated there's more than a
trillion dollars of
unspent cash sitting in in investors
bank accounts in the united states alone
right there is an insane amount of money
out there and and what happens is is
when
you know venture capital firms make a
bet and make a lot of money
people sort of say wow look how
brilliant they were how 40 you know how
much foresight
they had but the reality is that you
know they're putting
they're putting their chips on every
single number on that roulette table
every single number and getting paid and
getting paid to do it
and getting paid to do it and by the way
a percentage paid for everybody who
doesn't know two and twenty you're
getting two percent management fee which
incentivizes you
to raise as much money as humanly
possible because now you're making
i listen guy i you know this is a story
i don't talk a lot about
after i invested in facebook twitter
tumblr made my name
in that web 2.0 sphere before i started
vaynermedia
i had crazy money from billionaires and
family offices
uh thinking that i had the golden touch
and had an opportunity to make millions
of dollars a year just taking meetings
and getting 20
of the upside and chose to start an
agency
because i realized i would be more happy
being an
operator than an investor yeah i mean i
think that makes a thousand percent
sense to me
you know i i often talk about this and i
love that you're bringing this up
because
i i often talk about about what it means
to be an entrepreneur
and it's not about going out
and becoming the next airbnb or the next
uber that's not what it's about
it's about building something that
solves a problem that you have and other
people have
and and and trying to make a
contribution in some way to the world it
doesn't mean you're going to
save the world it doesn't mean that your
product or brand is going to
radically transform it but if it
improves something about it in some way
that is more meaningful than anything
that that almost anything i can think of
you know and and and so being an
entrepreneur building something creating
a product or service
is not it's it's not about scale it's
not about billions it's about
building something that allows you to to
have a sustainable
good interesting life including things
that
seem out of fashion which is like the
trickle down on your local economy
aspiring your your child's best friend
to do it as well
giving back to the community by donating
a bench or a park
or even you know some wine for the uh
local
kind of pta let's go back to you a
little bit here
so you're growing up in this environment
school school school and what kind of
kid
are you are you a bookworm kid are you a
sports kid do you have some
entrepreneurial dna like how did you
play out
that childhood yeah i mean as a kid i
mean like a lot of kids
i always loved um you know garage sales
and um
and car washing cars for money and so
you were very entrepreneurial
doing lemonade stands um yeah i mean
from the age of my
first job at age 13 was working at an
amp and mini market
the arco station around the corner where
i loved
doing full service because i'd get tips
for filling up people's cars and
washing their windows i mean it was
awesome i always worked you know and
this is a by the way this is also a
different thing i think
when we were younger than than it is now
when we were younger every kid i knew
had a job every teenager had a job
because that's how you made money today
it's different i think kids do a lot of
activities
and are kind of over scheduled and i'm
not i don't want to say this is better
and by the way you're talking general
trends obviously there's a million
families listening right now that have a
15 year old working
great and obviously and by the way to
your point it also matters what
neighborhood you're growing up in
that's right to your point upper middle
class and above scheduled
on 73 different activities lower middle
class and below
you've got a lot of people working
minimum wage jobs that's right exactly
um and as a kid i i loved i loved that
autonomy you know i loved being able to
do that
i i was really into sports i loved
playing sports i loved
playing all sports um it was pretty good
tennis but um
you know i wouldn't say i was a bookworm
i mean i was a good student um i wasn't
like the greatest student
um but i was i was it was pretty good
did you have an aspirational college
in like early high school you know
here's the thing i didn't
my parents emphasized education but they
weren't really focused on like prestige
education
got it they didn't care they didn't care
about status they cared about you
being grounded in it but you didn't need
to go somewhere so they could put a
bumper sticker
and and they could be you know crowd
chasing with that logo
got it not at all and they weren't it
was not that was not part of the
discourse in my house i mean they would
be happy if i went to
any state university in california you
know i as a kid
i was also really in our family we were
we talked about current events i was
really interested in politics i mean i
was really really passionate about
politics and so
um one of the cool things that that
happened to me was um
when i was 16 i actually went to
washington dc for the school year
to be a congressional page this is a
program that doesn't exist anymore
um it was it was stopped in the early
2000s but but every year
60 high school juniors would go to
washington dc and work on the floor of
the house of representatives
and i got this opportunity through my
congressman
to be a page and that was
transformational you know i i
it was an amazing experience to be there
as a kid and also to meet
kids from all over the country from
around the world from around the country
who
were you know from christian back with
super christian backgrounds and very
conservative backgrounds and
you know i came from a house that had
sort of mixed politics my mom was a
republican my dad was a democrat i was
always
as a kid when i was very young i was
like my mom i sort of
was really into republican politics when
i got into high school
i was really interested in the democrats
and i loved well i mean we're at exact
same age so like
you know it's very easy to think about
reagan and clinton
yes for me and i was also very very
interested and i you know i was also
born in the soviet union
in my early years i'm catching cold
world dynamics yeah
and you know i also had a lot of
interest played tennis did garage
selling so i didn't realize how similar
we were
which is really neat brothers from
another mother i love it i love it
so you so that makes sense to me where
you're going with your you know for in
my family
reagan was huge because we had made our
american dream during that time
he gets that credit for me as i got
older you know
clinton was cool and progressive and
socially about the things i was about so
it made sense yeah exactly
and that was that was sort of my you
know my kind of life and and i went off
to college and
really i think my plan was to do
something
in public service either in journalism
or in politics i was always
also really interested in that in high
school i did the student newspaper and
then in college i did too
so i was all i was already kind of
what state did you go to college in
massachusetts
and then what and then um after college
i
looked around for newspaper jobs and i
couldn't find i couldn't get one you
know because at that time i mean this is
now the
mid 90s 97 you graduated or 98.96 i
graduated college
if you were um like an ambitious
journalist at the time you would want to
work for a newspaper so
trying to get a job at a place like the
baltimore sun or the
star ledger in newark or the the boston
globe was
impossible like they they they took like
harvard and princeton
and yale graduates you know i could not
get a job at any of those places so
i actually stumbled into an internship
at npr
when i was 22 or 21 i think um
and that was i mean i didn't grow up in
an npr household my parents had never
heard of it they didn't know what it was
um they thought i was working at a radio
station i first heard it in college
i just like tuned the dial and i heard
the i heard car talk and i was like what
is this this is so crazy
this is so good i love this i want to
have like a potluck dinner with these
guys
um and that's sort of and i discovered
that they didn't actually work at npr in
washington
but um but that's how i got into
journalism and that's how it happened
and and that's kind of like you got into
in that world and
kind of stayed in it got into that world
and that was sort of my career
for the next you know sort of 15 years i
started out as an intern and at night i
was writing articles for the washington
city paper in washington dc this was a
time
when alternative weeklies really
mattered big time
yes i mean this was like you know the
editor of that paper was a guy named
david carr
who went on to become a legendary
journalist on his own like jake taproo's
on cnn now as a writer
tahasi coates the great you know like
intellectual writer
was a i mean it's an amazing group of
people so that's where i really kind of
cut my teeth and then
eventually became a reporter for npr and
very early in my career
had a chance to go overseas so i spent
almost six and a half years overseas
um covering eventually it ended up
covering war and conflict which
wasn't my intention but but after 9 11
you know many people who were foreign
correspondents became war correspondents
that's right where where'd you live i
was
both posted in berlin i was posted in
jerusalem
and i was posted in london but i really
didn't live in those places much i was
usually on the road
you know when i was in london i was in
iraq all the time or afghanistan
when i was in jerusalem i was in the
west bank or in gaza or
you know covering that conflict um so
it was a pretty amazing incredible
experience that i
you know family scared for your help for
your well-being um
yes they were they were but you know it
was a different time in my life you know
i was younger i didn't have kids um
my now wife was my then girlfriend
um and you know she i mean i i
for for two of those seven years
overseas i actually was a television
correspondent i worked for cnn
i was i was poached by cnn and then i
went back to
to work for npr for a few more years um
and my wife
saw me on television in iraq and with
like those night vision goggles of just
like tracer fire going around all over
me
she was freaking out you know she was
watching this from from from london on
on tv but um
but that yeah i mean it was a chapter in
my life in a really important and
powerful and profound
part of my life how did
you know this new show which is now a
book four years ago how did that start
well i um i became a news anchor at npr
um eventually hosted all things
considered on the weekend
and and then i left the new side of
things
um to start a new show called the ted
radio hour which was a
collaboration that i did with ted talks
and that was just an amazing experience
um
meantime in my head i always had this
idea for how i built
this and here's where it actually came
from so i'll go back in time for a bit
in 2007 i i was back at npr
and i really wanted to be a host of a
show i wanted to be the host of a
of an evening news show or one of the
new shows and at the time the executives
in charge of
deciding who could become a host
determined that i did not have the
qualities to be host
that i didn't have the personality to be
an npr host this
that i was a war correspondent and that
i i wasn't i didn't have the talent for
it
and it was crushing you know and and at
that time
i began to think that maybe this wasn't
the right profession for me that i
needed to find something new to do with
my life
so i really kind of flailed and searched
around
and i very luckily landed on an
opportunity to do a fellowship i applied
for a fellowship
i apologize for a second sure did you
understand that that was literally
a subjective opinion of a couple human
beings and qualified
no no not at the time that's why i
wanted to jump in right now because i
know somebody's listening right now
and i think you can really help somebody
right now because i think
what has absolutely worked for me in
happiness
has been when these things happen that
doesn't mean
the universe took a poll and said 80
of it was this subjective opinion and by
the way
a lot of times when you're dynamic or
have some skills
you're actually scary to the
establishment which leads to them not
seeing it
i think that's right um and and i
appreciate that you
paused to ask about this because you're
right it is important it took me a long
time in my life to come to that
realization now in my
mid-40s it's easier for me to see to see
it that way
but you know when i was in my early 30s
you know
30 31 it was very hard to see it that
way a respected
executive with experience telling you
you don't have what it takes
it means something and you believe that
and it and
and i wish i could go back and tell my
30 something you know 30 31 year old
self hey it's fine you got this keep
keep on it
in in many ways i needed that kick in
the butt though i mean i
didn't get rejected from any of the
colleges that you applied to i got
rejected from many colleges and i got
rejected from many jobs
okay you know and over the course of my
career which i can talk about in depth
um do you feel like that was easier
because that was systematic and you
understood that whereas
this one was a little bit more like you
thought that person really knew
yeah and it happened a few years later
it happened
it happened a few years later i mean i i
in in 2011
my dream was to be the the main host and
anchor of all things considered during
the week
and i wasn't picked for that they they
decided that i wasn't the right person
for that job and i was crushed you know
i thought
this is kind of the end of my career
that was only in 2011
you know and that but but the thing is
is that those two pivotal moments
forced me to kind of reimagine
and take try to take control over my
career so in 2007
when i was told i wasn't really capable
of being a host of a show
i looked around to figure out how to
transition i found this fellowship for
journalists
it was called the neiman fellowship i
did it for a year and that year was
transformational
um i got to spend a year at harvard
which is all paid for
i got to take classes at harvard
business school and it was during that
year actually where i
took a class at the business school and
was blown away because do you know the
way
i thought that business school was like
charts and graphs and abstract ideas
the way they teach business school is
through the case study method i'd never
heard of it before
it's basically stories and i was blown
away like
the first day i went to a class we were
handed this case study about
howard schultz and starbucks and i
thought oh my god this is these are
heroes journey these are stories
that can be told and i kind of filed
that in my in my mind
to kind of return to later on um and
then 2011
what happened when i didn't get that job
i wanted
it really forced me to rethink what i
wanted to do with my career and at that
time
i began to collaborate with ted as you
know the ted talks people to start the
show ted radio hour
on a podcast and by the way at the time
i was on the radio and all of my
colleagues
on the radio were like you're leaving
the radio to do a what a podcast who
listens to those
no different than people leaving
newspaper to go to blogs that's right
it what is or or executives in hollywood
i had friends
i encouraged friends five six seven
eight years ago in hollywood land
to go to netflix and many of them did
not
because they because of the perceived
step back
right you learn their lesson that if
you're thoughtful and you can see the
tea leaves
often the step back is the three steps
forward that's right
and i was nervous too i was like maybe i
am crazy you know leaving
this is 2012 you know leaving radio
diversity had forced you into a
framework
that allowed you to be a little bit more
comfortable
with it like those micro losses
put you in the mindset and the context
to
to make that move i had to i didn't have
i had nothing i had no other choice
really it didn't
there was no horizon for me in the using
the traditional path so
i started this podcast and it you know
it really blew up i mean
we kind of wrote a wave of of the kind
of podcast boom
and that's really what led me into you
know a completely different phase of my
career where
you know i eventually started a
production company and then i started
another production company and i made a
kids show
with i we we've got a kids production
company and then i you know we do how i
built this and
um and so all those failures along the
road
were actually meant to happen you know
they were meant they were
you know i'm not a believer and i'm you
know i'm i'm i respect people who
believe but i'm not but i i do
so part of me is like some things are
meant to happen you know and
and those setbacks which were really
hard i mean i remember a lot of
like sleepless nights and a lot of just
like feeling really bad about it
do you think they're meant to happen or
do you think
they well there's a way to think about
it
i i when you just said that i'm like
they're meant to happen to every single
person that's listening right now and
every single person that lives on earth
and one's perspective and what they do
with that the serendipity of their dna
of optimism versus pessimism
the naturing and nurturing environment
they live in
parent dynamics the neighborhood they go
into this place where
you know ever like it's amazing to me
what i think about
like how romantic i am about adversity i
would actually argue that the biggest
challenge i have at 45 right now is
do i make it harder on myself in
professional success
because i actually enjoy it so much the
actual adversity
the slowing down of the inevitable the
process so much
do you feel like they were meant to
happen or do you feel like they
inevitably happen everywhere and the
framework one is in
mentally enables them to see the
positive or
to start to dwell and think about
systematic issues or
blaming parents like the game of
dwelling versus
opportunity i think that it's very
natural for humans to to dwell
i think i think instinctively most of us
when we are faced with adversity at
certain points in our life
it's it's it's natural for us to feel
really bad about it and to
try and explain it and i think over time
the way you explain those things to
yourself changes right and so now
and really the only way to figure out
how to confront adversity is to
experience it again
and again and again right it's like any
kind of muscle
you just get better at it over time i'm
sorry to interrupt because i'm
passionate about this
one of my great fears was the
demonization of losing
yeah that parents modern parenting
again generalizing modern parenting has
created
we've demonized losing kids watch
parents fight coaches and parents
excuse me and teachers on behalf of
their kids when they're faced with
adversity
we've demonized it so much in the last
chapter still kind of now though there
is a
undercurrent of changing it a little bit
but i do feel a lot of
cliche 20 you know 18 to 25 right now
struggle because they were
put in a cocoon that really
demonized losing in a world where
repetition of it really does lead to
happiness thoughts
you know gary i think i have a theory
about this
okay so i'm sure you've come across a
lot of 18 to 25 year olds or maybe 18 to
30 year olds
who suffer from anxiety and depression
right for a variety of reasons the truth
is is that
i did too when i was in my my 20s
i experienced really like um
debilitating depression something i'd
never experienced ever before in my life
and by the way
i was on the fast track to a
quote-unquote successful career as a
young reporter at npr
but i had so much anxiety and fear
about the future and about whether i was
going to make it and and
i couldn't talk about it with my parents
because i didn't come from that kind of
culture when my parents talked about
depression
they thought mental health was for crazy
people right which was a normal
way to think about it in the 80s and 90s
i don't want to blame them but that's
how people thought about it
and i realized with time you know
you believe this is a stigma issue and
much like other things we've talked
about in society
this has been a continuum it's just
thank god we're in a place now where we
can talk about it more openly
and here's what i think i don't
necessarily think young people are any
different than we were gen x
i agree with you i don't think they're
any different actually i think they're
better i think they're more inspiring i
think they're more
they want to take take on the world in a
more inspiring way i think there are
more inspiring
and inclusive and open and woke and all
those things i do
think that losing was demonized for them
in a way that it wasn't for us
i think i think that part may be true
but i think the fundamentals are the
same which is think about it your whole
life
there for most young people there's a
track you know you go from first grade
to second grade then you go to middle
school and then high school
and then if you're lucky you go to
college and people are cheering you on
they're saying you got this and you know
what's coming up next and then a lot of
people go to college and
they develop their identity there they
might get involved in sports or
they might they might you know they
might organize a rally or a concert or
they're in the newspaper and they have
an identity
and then they graduate and everyone's
like yes you got this you got this and
then they
they they start life and the safety and
it's gone they don't know what's coming
next year
add to that all of this research we now
have about the human brain we know the
human brain continues to develop
that that your executive prefrontal
cortex continues to develop until age
30.
so there's a slosh of things going on in
your head at the same time
you're starting life out there's no
safety net and you don't know what
you know you're not going to grade 13
you're not going to the next year of
college
so it makes a lot of sense to me that
young people you know people in their
20s
are you know are there's they're so
susceptible
to being anxious and depressed because
of all these things happening and i
think really
the to me that the problem is we don't
talk about it enough we don't
and they don't talk about it enough
i i think there's some real validity to
that i really do
let's uh i don't want to run out of time
because i'm enjoying too much the combo
let's get into the book
quickly the the the show you know
it was an instant hit uh you know i
admired it so much from afar
we haven't had a chance to really
connect so i'm glad i get to say that to
you publicly
uh and then and then the transition into
a book and how you think about
that for you now that i have a good
sense of your context i'm sure it's a
pretty epic moment
yeah i mean um you know the the show we
started it four years ago
um and first episode the first episode
is sarah blakely
i love it what a great choice and it was
wonderful it was a wonderful episode
and you know what i what i and i think
you get this a lot too gary which is
like for a lot of people who watch
your your videos or listen to your
podcast or who follow you on social
media
you are their mba like you are their
free mba right a lot of people will say
that to you
and a lot of people say that to us too
and it's actually
an amazing thing to hear because i i
i believe that through the stories and
the experiences and the lessons
of and the granular grinding details
that you get from people like howard
schultz or sarah blakely
or tony shea or any of the people we've
had on the show
you learn what to do and what not to do
and it's funny going back to your
harvard hbs which is the apex of that
storytelling format and then the
serendipity of the people that are part
of your class
if you think about it you're putting out
these stories in a very dynamic modern
way
and your quote-unquote class
oftentimes are the people that you're
conversating with on the internet
about the episode on twitter or
instagram or things of that nature
yeah i'm not as good as you are at those
things i'm
pitifully horrible at it um but i you
know i i think that's right and i
i really wanted the show as i as i came
to understand that that's what the show
meant to people i wanted the book to do
that as well i wanted it to be a place
that
people could go to not only to kind of
have a framework a general framework for
how to think about starting a business
and all of the steps that it takes but
also just
um if you if you are interested in in
creating a disruptive idea
inside of your business inside of the
company you're at you know i wanted to
create
a book that was full of stories that
gave people kind of a mental
architecture and framework for how to
think creatively and how to kind of
unleash their creativity because i
actually and and you may disagree with
this and this may be a controversial
thing but
i i think there are some entrepreneurs
who are born i think you you were born
an entrepreneur for sure but i do think
it's
that most of the traits of entrepreneurs
are learned can be learned
you know what's funny people always have
me mistaken on this
i view it no different than tennis
skiing
yes cooking i could be much much much
better at tennis than i am right now if
i put in the work
yeah i don't believe that i was meant to
be
novak djokovic right and i think you
made a very important point earlier that
i've been fighting for in different
creative ways of communication which is
hey you're not it's unlikely that you're
going to build
spanx or zappos or uber or facebook or
what have you however isn't it
remarkable
to build a business that your family can
live on yes and you love doing it
no different than i am not destined to
be joker
but nothing more fun than to hack around
a tennis ball with my buddies
on a weekend in the summer so to me
i wish entrepreneurship i think all time
entrepreneurships beyonce lebron
sarah blakely serena williams i yeah i
think that's a born
dynamic with work put into it i think
there's a lot of people right i think
carol smith thompson could have been the
greatest tennis player of all time
she didn't put in the work or even
become aware that the skill was
in her so it goes both ways but i'm with
you guy i do think that
to your point do i believe somebody
listening right now who's an upper
middle management executive who loves
listening who has entrepreneurial
tendencies could buy your book
get inspired because they learn in book
form more than listening to me on my
podcast
and then bring a singular move or an
insight that starts a spark within the
org
that moves it a half a mile down the
field i believe that the most because
i'm an operator
i yeah i mean i couldn't have put it
better you know i think that's exactly
right you know i
i think let me know if you need the
forward for the next one i'll be right
back you are writing the board for the
next book it's gonna say with gary
vaynerchuk at the bottom of that
no but but i but i'm glad you brought it
up and i think it was a fair way to put
controversy and by the way
i i've made the mistake through my
career of speaking in sound bites
without clarity where you know i'm sure
there's videos where i'm like where
somebody's like
you know ten quick questions at the end
gary entrepreneurship born or taught i'm
like born
because i'm speaking about it in the
framework yeah exactly but i
i believe everybody look i believe
fear the ability to have a relationship
with fear
is 100 the trait that talks about your
ladder of entrepreneurship
my stomach for being wrong is so
big that i'm able to be very
entrepreneurial other people
making a mistake in a meeting in a
company by reading your book and one
little thing
petrifies yes can i can i build on that
that's exactly right people ask ask me
they'll say what is the one trait that
all the people in your show
you know that you've interviewed or in
the book have in common and people
expect to hear oh they're resilient
oh they're optimistic oh you know these
kinds of things
the reality is that they all have the
ability to withstand rejection
so it's it's it's similar it's it's it's
in the
same side of the other side of the coin
of fear right which is that
if you go to somebody and you say hey
gary i have this great idea it's this
product
we're naturally we naturally want
validation we want people to say that's
awesome
go do it but we're really scared of
hearing people say oh that sucks who's
gonna buy that that's a dumb idea
and and that is actually what stops most
people from pursuing their ideas
or you know going to two to ten people
to to raise money or or going to friends
and family to ask for support and
hearing no no no no
i'll tell you a quick story which is
i've had and this is very
very interesting i've had a a fair
number of mormon entrepreneurs on the
show
david nielsen joel clark of kodiak cakes
uh smith of cotopaxi and others and
to a person they will all tell you the
reason why they do what they do
is because they went on a two-year
mission you go on a two-year mission
okay you're sent to brazil or wherever
you're not
you're knocking on a thousand doors a
week trying to sell a religion to people
and 999 of them are slamming the door in
your face and you've got to be polite
and gracious and
keep going and those kids they come back
to utah wherever they live
at 21 they're ready to take on the world
couldn't agree more
i i couldn't agree more i i really
genuinely believe in the same way that
parents think about sending a child to
school
um you know more progressive parents
think about establishing
non-profit give back dna other parents
think it's travel
or sport the way many parents think
we're going to put our kid in sport
i genuinely believe the notion of
lemonade stand knock on doors and try to
wash cars
getting into that place of no no no and
then when they say yes
i mean my friend robbie turnik big shout
out to him
is reminding me that 70 of our childhood
first to eighth grade because that's
when we hung out
before i moved like 70 of the summer was
washing cars selling lemonade in the
winter it's
yes i'm trying to rally everybody to
shovel and so it's
no no no and then when somebody says yes
you have to shovel snow
for 20 minutes instead of sledding and
hot chocolate and and that formed me and
i'm the extreme
but a little bit of it a little bit of
it i think could really help a lot of
kids
i really do i completely agree and i
think that
and look i'm a parent i know you're a
parent i'm not
a perfect parent i'm not you know i i
don't stand up and say this is the model
and i i screw up a lot you know i there
are times where i find myself
coddling my kids too but i really do try
and be mindful of this idea that
they need to experience loss and failure
and
you know my kids played baseball before
the pandemic and
they would really lose their you know
they'd lose their minds when they
when they lose the games and i would say
that's part of the game like if you are
an amazing baseball player
you're failing seven times out of ten at
the plate and you're
amazing you know um which is why
the whole thing you're a hall of famer
you're failing 70 of the time
which is why i think baseball is a great
sport because it's a game of failure
um but you know you know funny
because of the batting 300 and so hard
but this is what's great about sports
and why people love it
hockey missing the net football dropping
the ball
basketball is i mean shooting
percentages are you kidding me right
you know at least 50 percent of the time
you know and then some and so
i i just i it's a i'm definitely
passionate about from a good place
because i want
kids to grow up to be happy and i do
think learning to lose early on is a
blessing yes and also learning to kind
of
take take control and have some autonomy
you know that's why i agree with you
that
getting kids to to to to build
enterprises even if it's a lemonade
stand or a cookie stand which which my
kids do you know obviously
pandemic era makes it harder but um you
know that
they walk away with 20 30 40 bucks i
mean
that's awesome i mean and then watching
what they do with it right do they want
to buy a toy do they want to save it do
they want to give it away
it just gives you great insight yeah you
know i think giving kids freedom because
again i think
back to communism and capitalism you
know because i was born and
one and flourished in another you know
this is a
freedom capitalism you know usa usa
meanwhile
parents spend an enormous amount of time
keeping their kids
in boxes yeah you know again i i don't
know how you grew up but we
we we grew up in the era where you just
went outside in the summer
and that freedom mattered and now you
know it just isn't that way
and it's weird because you know when
when we were kids like we would ride our
bikes
everywhere that was my mode of
transportation i rode all over the san
fernando valley on my
on my bmx bike you know um i'd go to
7-eleven with friends and we'd buy candy
and and um
same with me bmx bike to crousers just
the jersey version
and and now um it's much safer america
is a much safer country
much you know far fewer kidnappings etc
and we're
so much more protective over our
children it doesn't make sense
well it makes a lot of sense it's the
the
and you know this better than most
people the news coverage
and and ratings and fear and
tune in like and you and i grew up with
america's most
wanted being a hit show and you know
it's not super complicated
right you know the the tone and tenor of
what
was covered um on the news changed
yeah and that scared you know
you know a lot of a lot of people are
very confused how
effective fear can be yeah you know and
i think we see that play out in modern
politics around the world
not just in america and i think you know
it's it's um
this is where the cocoon the your four
walls as a family really really matters
yeah there's actually a really
interesting ted talk by michael shermer
about that very point and he argues that
the things that we fear um we fear
because because
um they're discussed or they're talked
about actually you know we're scared of
shark attacks
sure sharks are incredibly rare that's
right more people die in the bathtub
jaws right i mean i talk about airplanes
versus driving i mean like you know my
mom is still scared when i fly which is
always
and i'm like mom you should be scared
when i leave the house driving
you know like i'm with you like we need
to do a better job
i i talking about it in a way that
we need to find a way you know i can't
believe this guy literally this morning
i woke up
and said i i you know maybe it's this
wgn thing
right there's this what is it news
nation there's a new play you've seen
this
yeah i you know i've been thinking a lot
about
man i really really really think because
i think pendulums swing in society
i think there's a real opportunity for a
24-hour news network that is
based on positivity not not delusion
not delusion but but i believe in life
you find what you're looking for and
there's enormous amounts of beauty and
good
going on all the time and i think there
needs to be a scaled outlet
yeah i mean if if if that could be the
answer that would be great i mean
i worry that we're living in such a
disaggregated time
you know you think about information i
mean think about think about this for a
minute
in in the 15th century okay um you know
gutenberg comes up with the the the
printed press
and all of a sudden hallelujah people
can get a copy of the bible he can
prince it
he can distribute it but it takes 400
years
500 years for universal literacy really
to to kind of grow across europe
okay so so the the speed and scale at
which information
you know grows and develops is fairly
manageable for the human mind
well over the last 20 years we've gone
from dial-up internet
to snapchat to tick-tock to social
to instant you know communication and
information
that is almost impossible for us to
absorb
very quickly and it's happened on such a
just an insane time scale that
you it's not surprising to me that
there's so much disruption in the world
i'll tell you a quick story
in 2002 i was sent to afghanistan to
cover
that conflict and npr at the time had a
house there
that uh we used it was like our where we
lived and we had guards and and
translators and drivers they were all
afghans and one night
um i'm i get go downstairs get a cup of
cof a cup of
water and i can see the the back house
where the
the translators and the guards are all
hanging out and i could see a tv
flickering
now remember this is a population of
people who had never had
any outside influences there was no
satellite television there were no
insiders you know they hadn't seen women
they were watching satellite television
because we had a satellite and what were
they seeing on satellite television
half naked german porn
1 900 numbers now imagine how disruptive
that moment was right for that society
and i'm not saying
you're not making judgment you're
talking about information go ahead and
and and it speaks to this idea that
we have been kind of inundated with
information at a scale that we're
we don't have any precedent for you know
right the question becomes what's
foundational
in one's dna and upbringing
in how they decide to synthesize
information right i'm going to go
non-political i'm going to go a
different direction
i see the internet and i'm informed in
1993 456 that there's this internet
thing
i'm surrounded by liquor store
executives because that's
you know liquor store executives that
was being very kind people that owned or
managed liquor stores
in new jersey because that was the
cocoon i was in with my dad's world
i see this internet thing as the thing
that is going to change
my family's life the 80
other people in that cocoon that i lived
in saw it as the great
waste of time that my dad shouldn't even
let me
waste my time on that and they literally
made fun of my dad
for letting me build the website that
would go on to change his life
that to me is no different than mass
information
you know people i mean look we have deep
fake
brewing at scale it's already happening
yeah and it's good what that means is
the thing
that has affirmed information to us for
the last 100 plus years video
will now be debated as fake always
yeah which will then lead back to the
human spirit
and that is going to be very fascinating
to watch
i i think that's right and it's your
point about the pendulum swinging
i i i have to believe that that happens
because i think that the pendulum has
swung
so far in one direction now that um that
i don't think a lot of us like what we
see
and i think a lot of us want to see um
a more honest equitable and fact-based
world
the the issue is right now we're in the
place of
blaming everybody but ourselves yeah you
know right now we have enjoy like
watching people blame facebook as
an empty pipe and and
thinking that is any different that like
like it's amazing to watch the surface
level conversation
even by deep intellectual individuals
that don't have
any that have not gone past if facebook
disappears off the face of the earth
it's laughable that people don't
understand that humans
intend to communicate what they want to
communicate and more importantly
humans deciding to see what they want to
see whether that's on reddit
or a forum or search engines or a
one-off website
or fox news or fox news or cnn or
or news nation or their or their
neighbor's opinion
uh or during a coffee conversation like
this is
the greatest era of lack of
accountability
and uh and we're gonna have to go
through that pain
yeah and the question is how can we how
can we resolve it and i
i don't know the answer to it um but we
have well i can tell you one thing
it comes far more in the sense of
dialogue than it does to
cancel culture and right now we're in a
place where people politically in the
u.s
but i but i want everybody who's
listening because it's a global audience
to understand
this is to me not a donald trump joe
biden conversation we're having
there is enormous movements to
nationalism and different conversations
all over the world back to the place i
come from
eastern europe is going through a very
intriguing
transformation my homeland of belarus is
doing the reverse
they're trying to push out their
dictator of 26 years
uh and then there's just a million other
variables of meanwhile you have an
entire gen
z world that is feeling connected to
each other in a way that we've never
seen before
you've got blonde girls in la in love
with
korean boys that are look like you know
in sync and you're leading to just
incredible
dynamics and i think here's where i want
to go with it which is what's the
positive of this which is the following
if you're able to understand and i think
everybody should get this book because
i've been following
as most of you know i don't consume
things i consume people consuming things
and
the sheer joy and value that guys
program has brought to the table over
the last four
years to to the masses and to people i
respect
um and just his background and
communication style has me very hyped
for this book so i think everybody
should go and
get that guy when does this come out
comes out september 15th
available everywhere so like like you
always know vayner nation with me like i
always say buy it before the date it
comes out so go to amazon or
wherever you want right now and and get
it but i think
i think believe it or not 99 of the
world is seeing this
95 of the people around you right now
are seeing this as doomsday and i'm
moving out of the country and we're all
going to die
and this i view it as ungodly levels of
opportunity for you to
bring happiness to yourself or to your
children
because think of it this way if a
communication infrastructure has come
along in your lifetime
that is able to completely disrupt the
universe
in that there means to be so much
opportunity and if you choose to look
half glass full and go micro about the
things you can control
versus waiting to react to the things
that you can't
all of a sudden up pops arose out of the
concrete
and i hope and i hope you can get that
from the last seven or eight minutes
instead of where i know 98
of the mines went yeah i i i love that
and um and i love that because i think
that we don't have any other choice but
to see it
well that's right we we have to do it
right like
what is it that gets me out of bed in
the morning i've got two children
it's nine and 11 and i didn't bring them
into the world to leave them
a a world that was worse off like we
have no choice we have got
to solve our enormous enormous
earth scale global scale challenges from
you know
beginning with with climate change and
then everything else kind of
filters down from there but you know in
the united states we've got
huge equity challenges in in social
justice and racial
injustice questions to really grapple
with around the world you talked about
belarus and
i hope they can get rid of lukashenko
because he has been sitting there for 30
years
um you know you you we talk about the
resurgence of nationalism in countries
all around the world
these we have to hope and by the way
you're educated in politics
obviously you know the rise of that
leads to historically very not nice
things like
war at scale and genocide that's right
and so to me these but i want to remind
everybody because these are heavy topics
over the last guy you love us over the
last month 40
of acquaintance business associates and
friends have said the exact quote
it's never been this bad and then i go
into my
and i was a bad student except i was
always good at history and i realized
later in my life
it's because i love pattern recognition
i use it for business and it came
natural to me
with history and i said you know
literally this has happened
40 times in the last 100 days gary it's
never been this bad
and i reply you mean like the civil war
like you know like we are very we have
had a
very good run in the globe for the last
30 40 50 years
and i want to remind people that it has
been this bad
there has been the depression there has
been a civil war in america
there's been multiple world wars and
that's modern warfare
go back further than that and it gets
really gnarly i i think we need to
contextualize i understand
that things are heavy but i actually
have to remind you that there are you're
when you if you were lucky enough to
talk to your grandparents and
great-grandparents
they navigated very difficult times in
comparison
and uh and i think we need to be up to
the challenge i agree with you and i
think the
other th to add to that i think we have
this really privileged position where we
can learn
the lessons from those difficult moments
i mean there are a lot of parallels
between what's happening today and what
happened
in the 1930s in europe a lot of
parallels and i think if we
took some time to educate ourselves
about those parallels we can really
figure out a way how to navigate out of
it and how to avoid
the inevitable you know some of the
inevitable things that was things that
seemed
inevitable in the 30s which led to war
and conflict and and mass destruction
you know i think we are a precipice now
in world history where we do
have the tools to to develop
more empathy right and and and we have
the ability to communicate across
cultures across boundaries
in ways that were just unimaginable to
our parents and grandparents and those
tools can be used for horrible evil
things too but those tools can be used
for incredible
positive powerful um
powerful things as well i wish people
leveled up and realized whether you you
know and i
i have so many friends that see the
world on both sides of the aisle in
america and i just
i just remind them all the time of like
look if you're canceling
your friends and relatives that don't
see america the way you do
that will always always always lead to
bad for your children
because nobody's going to force 50
percent of the other side to
like this only gets resolved by getting
closer to the middle from both sides
right now that's just not the momentum
it's not the momentum
no um and the power levels are
incredible in business back to bring it
back
to which is which is if you don't
know how to communicate to your
customers to your employees
or to your bosses it is always going to
lead
to somebody losing whether that's you or
them for that matter and so
highly recommend you know compassion
sympathy compromise
as things that work not only in business
but in life
and you know what gary and you know this
i have a chapter
on this in my book i mean the the the
founders that we look for on the show
are kind we look for people who are kind
you know and kindness is uh
it sounds hokey and not to me brother
it's
kind of simple it's so simple
you know what's funny i have a family
that's very split
you know because just flat out the
circumstance of my family
has family uh i have one side of not
even one side
i have a lot of cousins relatives it's
very obvious to me
that kindness is very easy for me
because it is my natural dna
but i do believe that people that are
hurting with their own
voice with themselves kindness is
impossible
because what ends up happening is you
the misery loves company or the dragging
down
or the distribution of the pain you feel
inside of you
onto somebody else is a coping mechanism
of how to get the poison out of your
system and i
you know to me kindness is not hokey i
think kindness is the coolest
most admirable most important component
to business and life
on the flip side though i would
challenge and have started talking to a
lot of friends like i don't think
kindness is easy
if you're in pain i think it's actually
it's right you see what i mean
it's easy for me and i need to be
compassionate and empathetic that it
comes easy to me
and then be aggressive to be empathetic
to those that it doesn't come
it's back to like people that say you're
shitty on social i always feel
compassionate you were in such a bad
place
that you wanted to come to my page and
tell me i suck
wow you must have like i could i i i
don't have the time to go to people i
admire
and say you're doing great let alone to
go to somebody
and actually spit venom so you know wow
you're in a real kindness is hard to you
and i feel bad for you and let me figure
out a way to create dialogue that might
create
a little movement towards a little more
happiness yeah i love that i
and and i'm going to employ that
strategy next time somebody writes you
suck on my one of my social media
pages it's led to the biggest happiness
for me because you know
you know a little bit about me like when
i hit this will make sense to you i hit
the
social media scene early and the early
2006-7 twitter was very nirvana
like i laugh about how people view
twitter now yeah it was hippieville yeah
and i came in and did a little bit of
business and everyone's like this guy
and so i did feel a little bit of
pushback early on
and it was through dialogue that made me
such a big
part of the web 2.0 community because i
was listening i was like oh
don't talk about how twitter can sell
wine i see you see that as a bad thing
because you're going for a much bigger
thing i respect that look i'm trying to
feed my family this is the perspective
and it really helped me early on yeah
yeah i mean you know you're you're so
right
kindness is not easy it is a choice
um and it it can be a struggle for a lot
of people and i
i i think that's right but it also
it's also important to remember that
it's free it doesn't cost anything
and the return on that
behavior is i think bigger than any
financial investment you can make
i agree and it's been an unbelievable
episode i uh
i really i'm really glad i said yes this
i've been
very very head down you know
all my friends and contemporaries that
kind of want exposure for their projects
i'm gonna come on with tea with garyvee
we do it for 10 or 15 minutes but
when this email came across intuitively
i was like you know what let's get an
hour let's see
you know i haven't done an interview in
a while and uh and i'm really glad i did
and i'm really
optimistic and hopeful for your book and
continued success with the show
and uh and i wish you nothing but health
thank you gary thank you so much
thank you hey everybody on youtube first
of all thank you so much so humbled for
your time
i don't want to watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from
feel free to check it out